[Música]
yo nuestra sección económica la
dedicamos a Perú porque a pesar de la
inestabilidad política que ha habido en
este país la economía no ha sufrido lo
mismo o no Juan Pablo lucumí donde en
Perú ya ha habido seis presidentes en
seis años y aún así las finanzas van
bien así es Y eso es lo que revisaremos
hoy porque es una crisis política que no
es reciente que lleva varios años y que
en términos generales se esperaría que
si El Ejecutivo tiene problemas pues las
finanzas del país también se vayan en
picada pero si revisamos los niveles de
deuda pública del país veremos registros
bastante bajos frente al resto de países
de América Latina el desempleo pasó del
7,2% en 2020 al 4,8% en 2021 según datos
del Banco Mundial giraba la variación
del producto interno bruto en ese mismo
año fue positiva del 13,6%, una tasa 246
décimas mayor que la de 2020 que fue del
menos 11% para analizar este tema
hablamos con Luis Miguel Castilla ex
ministro de economía y finanzas Perú
quien desde Lima nos dio las razones por
las cuales el país sigue resiliente la
economía peruana ha tenido un desempeño
positivo por que tiene una serie de
aspectos los centrales que mantiene unos
fundamentos macroeconómicos muy sólidos
tiene los niveles de reserva con
respecto su producto más alto de la
región y la los niveles de deuda pública
con respecto al producto más bajos
a esto se le suma una Clara
Apuesta por la apertura comercial el
sector externo ha jalado la economía
nacional y y ha habido
una constitución que ha sido muy
conducente a que la inversión privada
sea el motor del crecimiento esto ha
hecho que el país
haya visto su pbi multiplicarse por tres
los últimos 20 años y se ha mantenido
relativamente el cliente pese a los
shocks externos que han sufrido
bueno de Perú pero
Juan Pablo Ulises de la región María
clara recordemos que la inflación ha
golpeado a varios países en el mundo a
Estados Unidos a la principal economía
de Europa Alemania a países de medio
oriente y de Asia pero si revisamos la
tabla de inflación de América Latina
vemos Que Perú ocupa los últimos puestos
junto con Brasil en sus cifras de
Incluso un dígito no ha llegado a los
dos dígitos y es mucho más baja que
países como Colombia o países como
Argentina y Venezuela que pues incluso
ya superan el 80% y que en el caso de
Argentina se espera que sea del 100% o
sea mucho más allá pero si nos enfocamos
solo en Perú quedan evidencia que la
tasa inflacionaria se ha mantenido por
ese Rango casi durante todo el año si
vemos se ha mantenido por el 8% y es
algo difícil que alcance algunos países
que ha hecho entonces Perú para que la
inflación generalizada en el mundo no
afecte tanto las arcas de ese país la
inflación que que ha sufrido El Perú al
igual que el resto de países de la
región ha sido una inflación básicamente
importada acá no ha habido una economía
sobrecalentadas sino un shock de oferta
que empezó con la reanudación de la
actividad económica Una vez que se
contuvo la pandemia inicialmente y luego
Obviamente con la crisis en en Ucrania
el incremento en el precio de los
combustibles de los alimentos ha habido
un incremento sustantivo de la inflación
Pero con esto dicho el Banco Central es
una entidad sumamente creíble Autónoma y
que ha escatimado esfuerzos incrementar
su tasa de de interés la ha subido de
manera
sostenida en 50 puntos básicos cada vez
que se ha reunido y además del Banco
Central también es muy importante el
papel del Ministerio de economía Qué rol
ha jugado esta cartera en Perú pues ya
el exministro nos habló de la
importancia de la independencia del
Banco Central el modelo económico de la
libertad de inversión y también como la
economía está blindada por algunas leyes
constitucionales Tres puntos en los que
varios analistas también han estado de
acuerdo pero con los constantes cambios
gabinete es difícil seguir la línea de
trabajo que pues esta línea se mantenga
sin embargo la cartera económica ha sido
una de las que menos movimientos ha
tenido y tal vez esta sea otra de las
razones del éxito macroeconómico en el
país andino el ministro de economía y
finanzas en el Perú y en general la
tecnocracia económica del país de alguna
forma han sido sustento de de muchos
años de de bienestar y de Progreso
económico en el país porque para el que
la acción de un ministro de economía y
finanzas en el Perú sea efectiva se
requieren de tres aspectos uno es el
apoyo decidido de parte del presidente
de la república un segundo aspecto tiene
que ver con una consistencia al interior
de gabinete
de ministros y los terceros un apoyo del
Congreso de la república para adelantar
reformas en distintos ámbitos dicho eso
el equipo técnico
es uno que permanece a lo largo de
muchos años y le ha dado y es sin duda
el Ministerio más importante del
ejecutivo peruano bueno Juan Pablo
interesante es estas posturas del
exministro de economía de Perú Gracias a
él por acompañarnos y gracias a usted
Juan Pablo por esta sección Nosotros
continuamos con más